my favorite time of the week the mailbag
first question from camille
hey michael i recently found out that
men and women both
value sense of humor when looking for a
partner but the way each sex
defines that is different women define
it as someone who can make them laugh
while men define it as someone who will
laugh at their jokes
i have also heard that men wouldn't want
to date someone funnier than them
now i'm not saying i'm a comedienne but
i humbly will say that i'm quite funny
do you believe the aforementioned
statements and do you think
a woman should tone it down when dating
a man at least early on
there is something to be said about
playing the game when it comes to dating
and not revealing too much
of yourself but what about being
yourself when looking for a long-term
partner
since that is what will create a deep
and real relationship thanks sincerely
funny how like i am you it's a great
name to sign off with camille
this is generally true men generally do
not care if women are funny men
generally
value a sense of humor in in women more
christopher hitchens wrote an infamous
essay about this
called why women aren't funny it was in
vanity fair
he said there were three carve carveouts
of of women who he said generally
they're not funny
but they can be funny if they are his
words not mine
hefty or dikey or jewish or some
combination of those things and and
you people were very offended when he
wrote this but then you always say hey
no some women are funny like ellen
degeneres
or like roseanne baro or like sarah oh
okay
and so it generally falls into that
category um however i actually do value
funny women
i do i will say this i know i know it
this is not
particularly conservative or traditional
of me
i really value how funny sweet little
ellie's is she's
she's genuinely funny maybe it's because
we grew up in new york you know
you get certain milia sometimes you get
people who are a little bit funnier in
those kind of places uh she is she's
genuinely funny and she
she will come out with a quip like a
really quick line and i love it and i
actually i
seriously value that but it is generally
speaking
men don't really care about that as much
because they find women beautiful
and women are just not physically
attracted to men in the same way that
men are physically attracted to women so
men
men have to be funny in order to attract
women which is uh
one of the reasons that things have
developed that way but but if you're a
funny woman
and you know especially if you fall into
one of the carve outs that christopher
hitchens permitted
then uh you know more power to you i
think it's great hold up
i'm glad you like that video you can get
the whole episode it's called the real
coup you can get it here on youtube if
you ring the bell subscribe
and you can get it on apple podcast
spotify google play stitcher
myspace zanga live journal aol instant
messenger hotmail
anywhere get it get it anywhere that's
the audio podcast you can also get my
book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
thank you to everyone who made it a
number one national bestseller
see you next time
[Music]
you